يوم واحد فقط بعد مقتل سته فلسطين في مخيم
جنين
يدخلان الى مطعم في محطه وقود قرب مستوطنه
عليه ويطلقان النار من اسلحه رشاشه
الحصيله اربعه قتلى واربعه جرحى في صفوف
المستوطنين احد المسلحين قتل في المكان
والاخر قتل في مركبه عموميه على بعد
اربعين كيلو مترا قرب مدينه طوباس عقب
العمليه اغلق الجيش الاسرائيلي جميع الطرق
المؤديه الى نابلس ورام الله وسلفيت وشرع
المستوطنون بالاعتداء على منازل
الفلسطينيين جنوب مدينه نابلس وسط دعوات
مكثفه لتعجيل تنفيذ الجيش الاسرائيلي
لعمليه عسكريه واسعه شمال الضفه الغربيه
الان دعا عبر وسائل الاعلام ويفترض انه
وزير في الحكومه فكيف به يخاطب رئيسه عبر
وسائل الاعلام يجب ان نخرج في حمله عسكريه
الان وكانه اراد ان يرسل له رساله بانه
بغير حمله عسكريه لن تكون هناك حكومه ماذا
سيفعل في ظل معارضه الشباب يمكن ان يخرج
في حمله متوسطه خصوصا للشمال الضفه
الغربيه واعتقالات ما في الضفه الغربيه
واقول بحذر قد تقوم الحكومه الاسرائيليه
باغتيال ما في غزه منفذاه العمليه بحسب
المصادر الاسرائيليه حضر الى محطه الوقود
الواقعه بين مدينتي رام الله ونابلس دخل
مطعما يسمى حمص الياهو وشرعا باطلاق النار
قتل احدهما وفر الثاني فنفذ الجيش
الاسرائيلي واجهزته الامنيه وطائراته
العسكريه حمله بحث ومسح لتعقب اثاره
بحسب المعطيات فان المنفذ الثاني تمكن من
الوصول الى الشارع الرئيسي واستقل مركبه
عموميه قتل بداخلها قرب مخيم الفارعه شمال
مدينه نابلس
العمليه شكلت ماده دسمه لعدد من اعضاء
الحكومه الاسرائيليه المتطرفين لرفع وتيره
الضغط على حكومتهم من اجل اقرار وتنفيذ
عمليه عسكريه واسعه شمال الضفه الغربيه ما
ينذر بتصعيد يطال مختلف الاراضي
الفلسطينيه
من الاراضي الفلسطينيه خالد القاسم
العربيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات